la fête la joie de se retrouver et pour
certains des gestes-barrières déjà
oublié des libertés assumer que ce
restaurateur d'une autre terrasse avoue
avoir eu du mal à contenir malgré nos
efforts c'était impossible de contenir
les gens les gens selon eux est
systématiquement passés 21h les
terrasses sont remballer ceux qui ne
respectent pas la règle sont contrôler
strictement mais pour certains clients
c'est parfois moins clair le couvre-feu
il est passé mais c'est important pour
toi de 20 noms marie le bac est avec
nous députés en marge des civils
commencent à dammarie soir ça après la
fonte en compte ses vues ben je suis
contente que vous mourriez un métier
enfin merci mme olive olive est avec
nous le gilet jaune que j'aime beaucoup
et ils vont y va il le sait or lui c'est
un oui il va je peux vous dire c'est
vrai il va tout droit
et il va tout schuss merci au niveau
élite comment ça va moins ça va ça va
tranquille merci les gilets jaunes vont
bien bon ça va à peu près bien
apparemment ça va à peu près bien le
citoyen en colère aussi un poste que
très bien c'est s'avancer il ya des
choses comme ce que regardent les ati
partie directe lycée s'adresser à son
truc
le premier jour du déconfinement est-il
un fiasco on vous pose la question pour
vous nicolas pernikoff oui mais pour moi
c'est un fiasco
les gens la fille de m oui mais les gens
sont passés d'un monde à l'autre on a
oublié les gestes barrière il y avait
des gens qui se parlent est à 20
centimètres l'un de l'autre sans masque
on picole on oublie le masque on oublie
les gestes barrières non mais je vous
dis un truc moi j'ai parlé avec un
restaurateur ce matin qui m'a dit je
suis hyper angoissé parce que j'avais
des gens j'étais très heureux de
réouvrir j'avais des gens partout sur ma
terrasse
mais il ya un moment donné on peut pas
non plus être des agents de police et
dit roland remettez votre masse match à
tobrouk il me dit on ne contrôlait plus
la situation
est ce que les français c'est sûr qu'on
te ronge tour les restaurateurs et tous
les gens qui roulent vers tous les
commerçants de ça on a peur on 6,6 à
rosser avec non mais ça n'aurait re
fermera pas les français ne supporteront
pas un nouveau confinement
on vient de passer 18 mois entre
confinement celui confinement là c'est
terminé si dans un mois vous annoncer
aux français qu'on re confine personne
ne vous suivra et ce qui est normal donc
un moment donné je trouve qu'on manque
de responsabilité où je suis désolé mais
nicolas un fiasco en une soirée déjà sa
lutte interne déconfinement pardon je
suis désolé évidemment que tout le monde
était à
so lu ment ravis heureux et que peut
l'être l'espace d'un instant il ya eu du
relâchement mais de là à parler de
déconfinement de fiasco par dont on va
très très vite en besogne moi je pense
que justement on était tous extrêmement
heureux on était tous très très très
très heureux d'être les uns avec les
autres allez pouvoir faire des boutiques
de prendre un café avec un ami qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis longtemps etc mais
que tout ça va rentrer naquit ça va
coûter la vie mais on n'a pas arrêté de
dire que les français
il est est il responsable et cetera pas
pas du tout ça fait 18 mois que les
français sont super responsable j2
restons titre au foot les chéris crew
l'estomac j'y crois un veston québec
marie lebel député en marque jean marie
non non non je crois pas que le
déconfinement c'est un fiasco chance qu
effectivement j'aurais été heureux de se
retrouver ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on
leur demande des efforts importants et
que dans la globalité on a eu un petit
événement hier effectivement à rennes
mais dans la globalité il faut regarder
sur l'ensemble du territoire alors on a
vu en terrasse à 21h30 21h45 couvre-feu
ils sont 10 c et c'est pour ça que nous
avons avec le renfort des forces de
l'ordre la possibilité de faire
appliquer cette règle je crois que ça a
été respectée il faut pas condamner les
gens croient qu'ils avaient
effectivement beaucoup de joie de
pouvoir se retrouver profiter et des des
restaurants et puis il faut aussi se
mettre je crois dans la position des
commerçants qui avaient pas pu ouvrir
depuis longtemps joué effectivement
j'avais une petite tolérance est ce que
le gouvernement a dit y ont fait ça
n'ont pas les yeux l'idée c'est de faire
respecter le couvre-feu on a des
confinement qui est progressif
je crois qu aussi pour rassurer les
commerçants ceux qui s'inquiètent comme
vous l'avez évoqué à l'instant il faut
aussi qu'on est un des fers de
déconfinement qui soit progressive parce
que c'est ce qui permettra de voir de
poursuivre la vaccination est de
continuer la décrue de l'épidémie
mon d'olive olives est ce que pour toi
le premier jour de déconfinement ça a
été un fiasco
moi alors je le répète un pour moi ça a
été un fiasco de la part du gouvernement
encore une fois de plus pourquoi je vais
m'exprimer là dessus il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont en train de s'insurger en
disant ol et distance n'était pas bien
respecté ceci cela je le répète une fois
de plus un j'ai encore d'arriver en
avion quand on monte dans un avion on
enlève le masque on nous sert à boire on
est tous les uns coller aux autres le
fiasco c'est quoi le fiasco c'est que
des gens on
la réouverture au bar et au restaurant
lors de ventes de 21h donc déjà le
service du soir
il est il est mort il est mort il n'y a
pas de service du soir il existe pas et
le plus gros fiasco c'est ce que vous
avez fait hier la république en marche
qu'elle a encore fait hier marie ont
annoncé du gaz lacrymogène sur des
citoyens encore pour pouvoir les évacuer
des hommes avec des mitraillettes devant
des femmes et des enfants pour les faire
évacuer des bars où fo redescendre sur
terre et il faut arrêter la répression
il faut arrêter vous craignez de montée
de la colère en france mais la montée de
la colère c'est ce gouvernement a de la
cré et face à holly vos livres sur ça on
a vu d'image un tous franchement marine
au bec je vous le dis là je rejoins
vraiment venir livre là-dessus quand on
voit des gens qui soient des terrasses
qui sont entrain de qui fait qu'ils sont
en train de voile à se dire on a peu de
liberté et qu'on voit même pour les
policiers je vous dis je pense vraiment
que c'est très compliqué d'aller faire
de la répression en terrassant les
étonner bah oui ça fait sous les balles
tous les jours c'est la police se sont
pas laissé une impression il se protéger
ils répondent à jean edouard puisque
live bien sûr qu'il ya eu des drames de
la police et on les a tous dénoncé ici
mais là je suis désolé la même tu crois
que vous croyez que ce gardien de la
paix la sas est ce un policier grec il a
envie de faire de la répression comme ça
au noir pour les personnes qui sont en
terrasse alors oui bien sûr ils doivent
être armés si les voilà mais on est
toujours en alerte attentats s'est
laissé forces de l'ordre en gelant
gouvernement de santé à la fois pour
prévenir des attentats et qu'est ce
qu'on dirait s'il se passait un
événement sur des terrasses on serait
encore plus choquée et on se demanderait
pourquoi le gouvernement n'a pas réagi
mais ce plan il est fait partie du plan
sentinelles il est opérationnel depuis
de nombreuses années et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes habitués à
avoir des forces de l'ordre qui se
baladent armée équipée pour faire non
pas pour faire maintenir leur n'a pas
envie de sur tous les joueurs c'est
qu'ils sont c'est pas pareil ans et vous
avez vu
vous avez évoqué le fait dire à rennes
on aime on a évacué les personnes avec
du gaz lacrymogène
on a eu un événement réellement je crois
que c'est important nous pas de faire
respecter et de faire respecter le
couvre-feu est ce que c'est la façon
dont va se dégonfler il ya beaucoup de
gens qui agissent de manière responsable
les commerçants aussi beaucoup accepté
de sacrifier sur leur emploi il faut
qu'on arrive à tous collectivement faire
et ce malgré la répression olive olivo
livre quand on comprend ce que dit au
niveau ligue et on comprend également le
plan vigipirate parce que c'est vrai
qu'on est en alerte maximale mais je
vais vous dire moi je pense que ça ne
fait même pas plaisir aux policiers
c'est vrai que en fait c'est mal perçu
c'est que les gens en terrasse se disent
ils commencent à flipper ils disent
c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression d'être
voilà d'être anodine et voilà en fait on
vous vend un retour à la normale à
retour à la liberté mais pas du tout ok
les restaurants sont ouverts mais à quel
prix et les restaurants qui ont été
menacés de fermeture at de fermeture
administrative aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
ont reçu un client en véranda
il ya des gens qui sont expulsés à 21h à
coup de gaz ils sont obligés vous alors
la lâchant pas d'accord avec ce que je
vous ai ya sinon ce qui va se passer
c'est qu'on va refermer dans le devoir
l'arrêter
vous allez encore pleurer mais non avec
les sangles et restaurateurs ils sont
réels r ils ont besoin de faire du
chemin de fer ils ont ils reçoivent un
pouf clients en véranda ils sont menacés
de fermeture administrative
ensuite on dégage les gens avec des à
coups de gaz lacrymogènes par bon mais
ces images employer un mot très dur mais
le centre mais je suis désolé vos propos
ils sont déplacés à être en temps quand
vous êtes en train de caricaturer où il
faut être plus la police mais ce que
vous pensez sérieusement on a parlé de
la baule et j'ai eu ça avant
non on a parlé de la police qui se
trimballent est là est ce que vous
pensez feront cesser les jardins
gouvernement m qui est ce qu audi a1
c'est le rôle de la police d'aller faire
de la répression et d'aller lire au long
maintenant il va falloir rentrer chez
eux maintenant vous parler franchement
c'est l'alarmé ils nous laissent
tranquilles non 99% des policiers me
laisse tranquille parlent et ils sont là
je termine ma phrase oui ils sont là
pour nous protéger les policiers avant
tout et il nous protège
on est en ce moment on est en risque
important d'attentats il ya tous les
gens qui sont dehors
merci à la police des plats pour nous
aider il n'y a pas que des crapules la
policia 1% même pas 1% des découvertes
policiers qui se comporte mal et tous
les policiers bien de les condamner sur
les plateaux télé
donc ce que vous dites là c'est vraiment
une caricature ce genre de photos de
reportage parce que istres à bâle pour
le sécuriser vous pensez bien qu'ils
sont pas là en train de menacer des
jeunes mais ne rentrer chez eux et de
l'armée azérie c'est important de le
dire je suis la dernière partie ce
panier merci nourdine réveil tom que
nicolas t'as vu des scènes ils sont pas
en train de se trimballer pour protéger
dans l'attentât ils sont là pour dire
aux gens mais si les protocoles en fait
il sera bien coach local depuis son
siège en dehors avec une norme comme
sont rentrés chez eux mais photocall de
la peur mais naturelle pour faire comme
si désolée non là c'est la vérité et la
république en marche et la république de
la peur et de la répression n'a rien
écouté par marie et je vais vous dire la
vérité à l'histoire au chaud et au
pardon
ok vous s'il vous plaît moi je voulais
dire un truc c'est que je vois les
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux et
beaucoup d'eau qui sont d'accord et
colis vos livres donc c'est à beaucoup
de gens qui disent voilà que c'est vrai
que c'est ils ont l'impression que c'est
disproportionné
donc vous dites qu'on est en plan
vigipirate est serré mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit cette image c'est vrai que
pour le policier c'est gênant et pour la
la foule aussi je trouve mais ils
patrouillent dans des rues où
effectivement il y à des terrasses
ouvertes pour protéger les gens ensuite
je crois que c'est beaucoup l'amalgamé
entre cette image et les événements qui
ont pu avoir lieu à rennes et encore une
fois on fait une faute
un focus très importante sur ce qui
s'est passé à rennes il ya peut-être une
dispersion malencontreuse de la part des
forces de l'ordre il ya aussi ce s'est
désolé le déconfinement il se passera
bien parce que à la fois tout le monde
joue le jeu et c'est ce qu'on appelle la
responsabilité individuelle
on a mis des règles on ne trouve que ce
sont des bonnes règles ou des mauvaises
règles chacun peut avoir son à un
arbitrage dessus mais il ya un
couvre-feu à 21h le consulat mais il ya
un couvre-feu à 21h avec des rails par
exemple si ce portable quand vous êtes
dans un restaurant c'est pas
le déconfinement c'est pas l'ouverture
de fête géante ça peut agacer peu
frustré mais il faut que tout le monde
tienne s'arrête parce que à côté vous
disiez il ya une personne dont on
accueille une personne dans une véranda
risque de fermeture administrative
c'est moi j'ai des restaurateurs sur ma
circonscription ça fait plus de presque
plus d'un an qu'ils ont pas pu
travailler ou alors ils travaillent en
dématérialisé à travers des plateformes
de livraison ils sont frustrés ils sont
en souffrance eh ben ils n'ont pas envie
de voir parce qu'un de leurs collègues
ne tient pas la règle de devoir refermer
dans deux mois comme des sirènes je suis
désolé c'est ce que tout le monde joue
j'essaye nouvelles à raison là dessus
marine et les magpies mots-clés mec joue
il faut que les mecs jouent le jeu si
l'on sera refermée dans de mauvais temps
d'un bal
olive olive nos robots géants rien à
rajouter là-dessus mais à chaque fois je
finirai là-dessus mois par rapport à ça
c'est on pense que ces règles sont
bonnes mais arrêtez de penser demandé un
peu aux citoyens ce qu'ils en pensent
eux parce que normalement vous êtes là à
l'écouté des citoyens
vous n'êtes pas là pour décider de vos
rêves mais rassurez vous il y avait
beaucoup de temps sur les berlin comme
ça ou non mais arrêtez je dirais minutes
chez moi ça marche mais mes parents mais
je passe beaucoup de temps sur le
terrain sur ma circonscription ballon
passe autant avec les personnes qui sont
des citoyens comme les citoyens disent
que vous les aimez mais jamais je
n'écoute jamais qu'on a voté pour
quelqu'un qui doit capter les programmes
maintenant j'essaie de comprendre la
colère d'olive olives
c'est quand même été vous n'êtes pas de
la récession vivre en france et des
coups que vous vivez dans l'un des plus
beaux pays du monde en ce moment
rendez vous des dpu chine je vous
parlerai même pas au lycée ouvert comme
un vrai c'est justement dans les salles
mais on va continuer passé et on est con
si c'est pour ça qu'on prend pas cette
colère en fait cette haine on a
précédemment laquelle de l'avantagé
s'expliquer pourquoi tu la comprends pas
parce que moi ça fait trois ans que je
suis dans la rue et toi tu sais pas ce
que c'est la rue vas-y arrive de réviser
un peu dans la réalité de la france
non mais moi jacques réalité de la
france parce que vous êtes complètement
déconnecté moitié des coiffeurs pet shop
est aujourd'hui avec chaque fois je le
dis on peut pas se mettre ici à la place
des gens voilà vous avez tout votre
opinion vous pouvez voilà mais c'est
vrai que on va se sentir ici on y est
vous êtes des privilégiés et je suis
d'accord sur ça avec au niveau livre
aujourd'hui bien sûr et c'est très bien
ce que vous dites aussi steevy c'est
vrai que mais c'est vrai que mon nez
quand même des privilégiés et c'est ce
que je dis à chaque fois quand les gens
se tournent vers les extrêmes ce soit
d'un côté ou d'un autre
c'est parce qu'aussi c'est les gens qui
sont en extrême souffrance qui sont dans
la rue depuis des années qu'ils voient
que ça n'avance pas que ce soit à gauche
à droite au milieu et qui sont voilà
dans une extrême tristesse et une
extrême joue ni souffrance n'est qu'un
moment ils disent
vers qui on va se tourner et c'est vrai
que nous aujourd'hui on peut pas se
mettre à la place de gens qui sont
vraiment à la rue depuis des années
qu'il voit pas qui on veut traverser la
crise nous on a eu la chance de
traverser la crise du coc vide ici sur
le plateau on doit continuer à
travailler pendant qu'il ya des mecs
vous dire qu'ils étaient 1 à 2 hors qui
était déjà dans la merde c'était déjà
dans la merde et je suis encore plus
dans la merde maintenant alors il ya eu
beaucoup d'être du gouvernement c'est
vrai mais c'est aussi de l'aide pour des
gens qui avaient déjà 20 des commerces
qui ont peut-être pu sauver leur
commerce et c'est très bien mais c'est
vrai que les gens qui étaient dans une
merde noire avant le coc vide nous
imaginons ils sont maintenant que tu en
voilà
curieux de savoir le nombre
d'entreprises qui malheureusement sont
tombés et il faut que tout le monde
prenne conscience en fait des choses il
y en a beaucoup qui se sont maintenus
parce que j'avais des aides et ce qui
s'en suit mais qui vont tomber après
derrière parce que le redémarrage is
fait ben voilà on peut remplir que des
terrasses à l'extérieur on peut pas
remplir un essai cessé de faire le
maximum voire comme une grosse précarité
je suis d'accord mais oui je suis
d'accord et je peux vous dire que la
rentrée est là la rentrée septembre est
extrêmement difficile et on va essayer
de petite échelle des 10 le maximum de
gens parce qu'il y aura énormément de
monde à aider je vous le dit et il ya
énormément de gens qui m'arrêtent dans
la rue et cet hiver il va falloir
vraiment aidé à fond les plus démunis je
vous le dis parce que ça va être violent
oui j'ai dû garder moi je comprends le
cri du coeur d'olive olives et madame
très franchement c'est aussi votre
chiasse cossa c'est à dire que cette
pseudo libération d'hier soir elle a
fait croire aux gens que tout était fini
et du coup vous vous retrouvez obligé de
réprimer pour réprimer à rennes presque
sauvagement madame je sais qu'ils
avaient des mairies valérie je sais
qu'ils avaient des jusqu'au boutistes
mais regardez ces images quand même un
feu de joie qu'il devait une répression
policière les policiers avec les
mitraillettes sam adams est grave france
en valeur
ça y est vous revenez sur un truc dont
on a parlé gilles verdez merci je
voudrais voir se compose ses
téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît merci
oui à cinq cabanons à 46 ans est serré
mais